The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK.
The weekend is over.
One announcement.
Last weekly test will be
tomorrow, and it'll be based
on homework 11, focused
on polymers.
And then the following week
is the very last week of
semester, and there's no
testing, no work required of
you, when the subject
has a final exam.
And this one has a big final
exam, big celebration, so
there will be no weekly
test next Tuesday.
So this is the last one,
so get out the Kleenex.
All right.
So today we want to continue the
treatment of biochemistry.
Last day we started looking at
proteins, and the building
blocks of proteins
are amino acids.
And so we looked at the basic
structure of amino acids,
shown here, which is an sp3
hybridized central carbon,
which I've designated
alpha carbon.
And three of the four
bonds are the same
in every amino acid.
Every amino acid has,
off the central
carbon, an amino group.
This is the nitrogen
with two hydrogens.
It has a hydrogen, a lone
hydrogen, and it has a
carboxylic acid, which
is this COOH.
Double bond here, I'm looking at
four sticks off the carbon.
One, two, three, four.
And this proton here is the one
that can fall off and go
over to the side.
And when it does so, then
we end up with the acid.
It's a proton donor.
And then the fourth bond
is this designated R.
R is the substituent, and
it could be anything.
We could put a cyanide
up there, if we want.
Anything that conforms to this
architecture with whatever
choice of R is still qualified
as amino acid.
There are only twenty
choices of R that
are found in protein.
We also studied chirality,
which is handedness.
Some of these amino acid
molecules are chiral.
That is to say, if you put this
carboxylic acid in the
lower left, and the amino group
in the lower right, you
have molecules that are
seemingly identical, but not
superimposable.
We call them chiral.
And the two forms are
called enantiomers.
And only the L-enantiomer
is found in proteins.
And we saw that the L is
determined on the basis of
polarization rotation
of light in an
aqueous solution of this.
Except for lycene.
In the case of lycene,
we have H up here.
So we have an H above
and an H below.
That molecule is not chiral.
So nineteen of the twenty amino
acids that we find in
proteins exhibit chirality.
And later in the lecture we
started looking at aqueous
solution behavior of
the amino acids.
And what happens is, when they
dissolve in aqueous solution,
they form zwitterions.
Zwitterions by proton
transfer.
So the proton goes off the
carboxylic acid and joins the
amino end, so you have a plus
end and a minus end.
And then we looked at what
happens with the behavior in
aqueous solution, and
we came up with the
Henderson-Hasselbalch
equation.
And here it is, plotted.
This is the case for alanine.
In the case of alanine, we have
the methyl group here.
So the R is CH3.
Everything else is the same.
So you can see that here's the
neutral zwitterion, where the
H off of the carboxylic acid,
has transferred over
to the amino end.
We have charge neutrality.
The molecule started off net
neutral, and now the plus is
over here, conferring a positive
charge to this end,
and leaving this end less
a positive charge,
and therefore minus.
So it's globally neutral, but
locally positive and negative.
Hence the term zwitterion,
because it's essentially dual
gender, both positive
and negative.
And we looked at the aqueous
solution behavior of the
zwitterion, and we saw that
zwitterion is responsive to
its environment.
And we reasoned that this is
how you start to impart
animation to something.
How do you get something
animated?
You get something animated by
having it respond to its
environment.
A rock sits there.
You can talk to the rock,
nothing happens to the rock.
But animated objects, if they're
endowed with hearing,
if you talk to them, sometimes
they respond.
So what's going on there?
It to do with the ability
to respond chemically.
And so what we saw
here is, when we
went into low pH regime--
low pH means very, very high
proton concentration.
The zwitterion responds by the
le Chatelier principle to try
to minimize that acidity.
So it gobbles up protons.
And over here we see that
it gobbles up protons by
attaching to this carboxylic
acid end.
That's a proton attachment
site.
And in the extreme, all of the
zwitterions have been capped
by protons.
So over here we have complete
protonation, and that's what
we're showing in this graph
here, which is just basically
the one that's up on the
screen, but I'm using
different-- see, this
is taken from one
of the biology readings.
They say equivalence
of hydroxyl.
There's no hydroxyl here.
I don't know how these--
you know, the language of some
of these branches of
science puzzle me.
That's equivalence
of hydroxyl, but
we don't have hydroxyl!
It's all about protons.
So here it is, in terms of the
equivalence of H plus.
So here's the neutral
zwitterion.
That's this thing here.
And this H, if it falls off, it
can then become the neutral
zwitterion.
And then what happens is, as
we go to very, very low pH,
what happens is that
the zwitterion
starts attaching protons.
So this is a neutral zwitterion
to which we've
attached the H.
So it's much--
to me this is transparent.
What this reads--
I don't know.
Equivalence of OH?
There's no OH.
That's a way of saying it's
fully protonated.
BUt to me that's sort
of a backwards way.
Don't tell me what it isn't.
Tell me what it is.
So this is fully protonated
over here.
And as the pH rises, the
zwitterion feels less
compelled to gobble up the
protons, so it sheds protons.
And finally the pH gets to a
point that's high enough that
the zwitterion plays no role,
and it exists as the neutral
zwitterion.
That's the isoelectric point.
We have a 100% concentration
of zwitterion.
Then we go to the
other extreme.
The other extreme is
the high pH regime,
where it's proton deficient.
And so zwitterion
responds by--
what?
Throwing out hydroxyls?
No!
In spite of what's written here,
there are no hydroxyls.
What zwitterion does, is it
tries to shed protons to
compensate for the proton
deficiency.
And so some of the HAs become
just A minus, because the H's
are being liberated.
And over here at the extreme,
all of the zwitterion has lost
its H here.
And so now you have something
that's net negative.
Over here you have something
that's net positive.
In the center it's
net neutral.
So this is the high pH regime,
low pH regime, and this is the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation,
which answers the
question, what is the ratio of
neutral zwitterion to either
the deprotonated form or
the protonated form as
a function of pH?
You tell me the pH, and I'll
tell you what the ratio is.
Last thing that's really cool
about this, and shows you the
power of this mechanism of
attachment or detachment, is
as follows.
Look at here.
This is not exactly to scale,
but it's reasonable.
You see the pK?
This is pK1.
This is for the protonating
reaction.
So over here I have neutral
zwitterion, over here I have
no neutral zwitterion, all
the zwitterions are fully
protonated.
And in between, I've got--
this is supposed to be sort
of halfway across here.
So this is 50-50.
But look at what happens.
For very, very large changes
in ratio of zwitterion to
protonated zwitterion, the pH
doesn't change that much.
The pH changes a lot here, and
it changes a lot here.
But over a vast expanse of
protonation or deprotonation,
the pH kind of hovers
around pK1.
So the zwitterion is really
doing its job.
It's trying to hold that
solution from shifting pH
dramatically.
We say that zwitterion, by doing
so, acts as a buffer.
A buffer holds pH
near constant.
And the near constant value
it's going to hold
it to is its pK.
So in the acidic regime, in the
very low pH regime, over a
broad range of protonation
deprotonation, it's going to
be roughly a pK1.
And the same thing happens
over here.
You see?
Over a broad range of A minus
to HA, the pH kind of holds
around pK2.
And then finally, over here, the
system gives up and then
it shoots up to the
100% deprotonated.
So that's the story there, and
you see the isoelectric point
in the middle.
Now, so far all we've done is
we've said what happens when
we have a simple amino acid that
has just the one proton
attachment point on the
carboxylic acid
and the amino acid.
But it can get more
complicated.
And there is an example in the
homework that you might want
to look at before
the final exam.
And that's the case where the R
group itself has the ability
to protonate or deprotonate.
Suppose this R group had
a COOH ending here.
Can you see that it could
also participate?
And so then the isoelectric
point isn't simply going to be
the average of the
pK1 and the pK2.
Because now there's a pK for
this thing, as well.
So this is the example
of the tritratable--
that's the term they use.
If I could just spell it, I
could convey the information.
Titratable R group.
That's what they're
talking about.
Otherwise, if the R group is a
neutral, it's just a spectator.
Doesn't doesn't participate
any more than this.
See, here's a hydrogen.
Look at this one, people.
You see this hydrogen?
It doesn't participate at all.
Please don't tell me at some
point that the zwitterion
says, I'm out of hydrogens
from here, I'm out of
hydrogens for here, I'm going
to start shedding this.
This is a really strong
covalent bond.
It's not going anywhere.
If you want titration, you've
got to put the titratable R
group up here.
OK?
This is so cool.
So now, I'm going to show you
an application of this stuff
that's used in biology.
And I know, because one year
they gave a crash course for
engineering faculty in biology,
and we did we
actually did this experiment
in the lab.
So I'm going to show you how
you can use the fact that
zwitterion changes in response
to its environment in the
laboratory.
So what we're going to
do is I'm going to
make a column here.
This is a column, and it's an
aqueous solution, a column of
varying pH.
So it starts at the top, and
just for argument's sake, I'm
going to put high pH here at
the top, and low pH here.
So it's an aqueous solution.
You can say, wait a minute.
He just taught us fixed laws.
This is proton deficient
this is proton rich.
Aren't the protons going to go
north and the hydroxyls are
going to go south?
Yes.
So what are we going to do?
We are going to slow
down diffusion.
We're going to change the
diffusion coefficient, and
what we're going to do is, we're
going to fill this with
a solid suspension and
turn it into a gel.
So what's the function
of the gel?
Don't say that Professor
Sadoway said
that he stopped diffusion.
Diffusion goes on, but it
goes on at a slow rate.
So over the time duration of
the experiment, for all
intents and purposes, the pH
changes imperceptibly in
comparison to everything
else that's going on.
It's all about time scales.
You realize, we are all aging.
We've been aging ever since
I started this lecture.
But for all intents and
purposes, we can view
ourselves as being the
age we were when we
walked in the room.
And even over the semester,
chances are.
All right?
Now if we meet back here in ten
years' time, expect to see
some changes.
Right?
But over the time scale of the
experiment, we can say we take
diffusion out.
So that means the high pH is
here, the low pH is here.
Now what I want to do, what is
it I'm trying to accomplish?
I want to separate an
amino acid mix.
And just for grins and chuckles,
we're going to have
A1, A2, and A3.
Three different amino acids.
Which means just three of
these things, but three
different R values.
I'm going to pour
them the top.
I've got this aqueous
solution, got
all three amino acids.
So what happens when
they fall in here?
When they fall in here, they
start diffusing, too.
Right?
Well, first of all, they hit a
very, very high pH regime.
So what what's the immediate
response to those amino acids
in a high pH regime?
They're all amino acids.
They're all those rescuers.
And they say, Hi, pH.
It's proton deficient?
I can help!
And they all start
shedding protons.
And so within moments,
all of those amino
acids have been totally--
as they say in California--
totally deprotonated.
And here it is.
So they're all sitting there,
in net negative.
They're all sitting there in net
negative, right up here.
But I just told you, I shut off
diffusion, slowed it down.
But I want to get out of
here before dinner.
So I don't want the protons
moving, but I do want the
amino acids to get moving.
So what do I do?
I put on my elecrochemist's
hat, because as you know,
electrochemistry is the highest
form of chemistry, the
most noble form of chemistry.
It happens to be the
area that work in.
And so what we do is we
electrify the ends.
And we'll polarize
the top negative
and the bottom positive.
Well, I just poured in a bunch
of amino acids that became net
negative, and now they're next
to the negative electrode.
So what happens?
Now they're in an electric
field, and they start moving.
They start moving in the
electric field, and they're
all net negative.
But what happens, is they
move down here.
So this is medium pH.
Can you see?
I've established the
pH gradient.
And as they move from high pH
to medium pH, the proton
deficiency isn't as intense.
So they're responding to
their environments.
They're saying, you know, back
there I had to get rid of all
my protons.
But now, it doesn't feel so
proton deficient, so I can
start taking protons on.
They respond to their
environments.
So here, they're
all A minuses.
And if they ever get down here,
they'll all be HAA pluses.
And so what are they in here?
They're sort of on their
way to becoming HAs.
Because the pH is continuously
variable.
So as they become less negative,
what happens to the
driving force by the
negative electrode?
It's weaker.
So the protons were, first
of all, they're anions.
They're net anions.
They go, whoa!
Negative!
And they start moving, and then
they get less and less
negative, and the field gets
weaker and weaker.
And eventually, they take on
enough protons that they
become neutral zwitterions.
And what is the response
of a neutral ion
in an electric field?
Nothing.
It stops.
And so let's say, this happens
to be the isoelectric point of
amino acid number 1.
So it gets to the isoelectric
point, and it
doesn't move anymore.
And number 2 and number 3 keep
going, and this might be the
PI of have number 2, and this
might be the PI of number 3.
And now I want only amino acid
number 1 from this mix, I can
now go in-- this is a gel.
It's put down on the
glass plate, or you
can put it in a column.
Now you where they are.
You come in--
because you've got a pH meter,
you know where this is.
You know the PI.
Bingo.
That's where they are.
And if I want number 2,
they're right here.
And number 3, they're
right here.
So this process is called
gel electrophoresis.
This is the term.
It tells you nothing
about the process.
It tells you how
to conduct it.
You make a gel, and you
polarize the ends.
Electrophoresis is simply
particles moving in an
electric field.
You can paint a car this way.
Obviously the car, when the
car is made of metal.
If you have a fiberglass body,
you can't use electrophoresis.
The car is made of metal, you
polarize the car, and the
paint, the paint has
got dipoles.
And so the paint sticks
to the car.
And then you lift it out, let it
drip, and then just get the
right amount of paint
proportional to the charge you
put on the car by
electrophoresis.
What's that got to
do with this?
It doesn't talk about
the focusing here.
So the mechanism here is called
isoelectric focusing.
So isoelectric focusing is the
principle by which we can
separate the amino acids
from one another.
The gel electrophoresis column
is a device in which we do so.
And let's be modern, so we'll
give it a three-letter
initialization.
IEF, isoelectric focusing.
Isn't that cool?
Yeah.
I thought so.
Anyway.
OK.
Everybody's still zoned out
from turkey or something.
No response.
This is brilliant.
It's beautiful, and it
integrates all of this
material, and deadpan.
All of this withholding love.
You've been with your families,
I can tell.
All of the old family
dynamic, see?
It's here.
You brought it with you.
Leave it!
Leave it at the airport.
OK.
Now.
So we've been talking about
the amino acids.
We said we're going
to use these as
building blocks for proteins.
Let's build some proteins now.
So protein synthesis.
So we're going to make
macromolecule.
What are we making?
We're making a macromolecule.
Protein is a macromolecule.
You notice I didn't say polymer,
because a polymer
going to have--
every element along
the backbone is
going to be the same.
But I'm telling you that we can
change the choice of R at
every station.
So it's a macromolecule,
but it's not
necessarily a polymer.
But we do know, if we're going
back a macromolecule, we've
got two choices.
Addition or condensation
polymerization.
So I look at the basic
structure--
let's put it back the way we
found it, so that people don't
leave thinking that we have
two carboxylic acids.
So the most the most general
form doesn't have a titratable
R group, but it does
have an R up here.
So I want to take one of these
and link it to another one.
So how do I do it?
Well, right off the
bat, addition
polymerization is no good.
Because even if I had enough
energy in my body to form a
radical, what could
I do with this?
There are no double
bonds here!
bonds here.
I can't break a double bond and
then allow this to bond to
its neighbor.
So axiomatically, I have
to go with condensation
polymerization.
OK?
Macromolecule formation by
condensation reaction.
I don't even want to say the
word polymerization.
By condensation reaction.
OK.
So let's look at an
example here.
An example will be this.
I'm going to write,
here is the COO R.
So I'm going to show this,
and then over here--
well, maybe I'd better show
some fine structure.
I'll give you a little
more fine structure.
So we'll put the double
bond up here, O minus.
And then over here, I'm
going to put H3N plus.
So here's the neutral
zwitterion, agreed?
And I've got some kind of
an R group up here.
And I'm going to put next to
it a second one of these.
So here's the alpha carbon,
and we'll go COO.
And then over here, I'm going
to unpack this nitrogen.
It's got one, two,
three hydrogens,
and it's net positive.
So there's the neutral
zwitterion.
So now by condensation reaction,
what we'll do is
we'll take this oxygen off of
the left amino acid, and we'll
take two of the hydrogens off
of this amino acid, and we
will eject a water molecule.
We'll eject the water
molecule.
And that's safe.
It's compatible with the body.
And now what's left?
This carbon is naked.
One, two, three.
There's a bond sitting here that
used to go to the oxygen.
And this nitrogen, it's
sitting naked too.
And so now we can do, is we can
make a link between this
carbon and this nitrogen.
And this bond is called
the peptide bond.
This is the peptide bond.
OK?
And we see that the atomic mass
of the dipeptide is less
than the sum of the masses of
the individual components,
because we've lost the water.
So I think I've got
some slides here.
What's here?
Oh.
This is just the various,
pK1 and pK2.
And then this side chain here,
this is the value of the pK
should you have a titratable
R group.
That's why there's the
third column here.
So when you see this--
you see, they're all roughly
around two for the highly
acidic regime, and all around
high nines, low tens for the
alkaline regime.
Roughly the same.
All right.
Now connotation polymerization.
This is the formation
of nylons.
You see how you bond this
mer to the adjacent mer?
Look at this.
The nitrogen, that hydrogen
is sticking up.
There's the nitrogen bonding
to the carbon.
There's a long pair, and
nitrogen-carbon.
Amide bond, peptide
bond, same thing.
The same bond in the backbone
of nylon is the same bond in
the backbone of protein.
Only, the biologists call this
the peptide bond, the polymer
scientists call this
the amide bond.
Think about that when, you know,
the holidays are coming,
you think you're really special,
and you know, the
proteins in your body are really
bound the same way that
nylon is, you know?
All right.
So now let's consider--
and here's some examples.
Here's a peptide.
So it's a long chain here.
So it starts, here's the
amino group, H3N.
It's got glycene, and then
leucine, and valine,
glutamine, et cetera.
So there it goes, all the way
around, around, around,
around, around.
And here's another one.
There's the amino group, and
then, boom, boom, boom.
What's happening here?
All of these click stops
along here are this.
H2NCHCOOH.
And the only thing that's
changing is the R group.
If this were nylon, it
would be the same
thing, all the way down.
That's how this differentiates
itself.
All polymers are
macromolecules.
All macromolecules
are not polymers.
These are not polymers, but
they are macromolecules.
And what else do you see here?
Look at this.
Cysteine happens to have
a double bond.
A residual double bond
in its R group.
Well, where you see a double
bond, you go, I can break the
double bond, and then I can
make a another bond.
And that's what happens.
So we break the double bond with
the sulfur, and now we
make a disulfide linkage.
What do you think the mechanical
properties of this
protein are?
Mechanically, what do you
think this one's like?
It's rubbery.
This is an elastomer, because
you can move the top chain
vis-a-vis the bottom chain until
these disulfide linkages
are flattened.
And then if you let it
go, it springs back.
It's the mechanical properties
of, in this
case, this is insulin.
Now I want to give you a sense
of the variety here.
How much information--
because ultimately, it's all
about reproduction, right?
That's the number one function
of any living
organism, is to reproduce.
That's what makes it life.
Right?
So it needs an instruction
set.
And the instruction set doesn't
come in the box.
It comes inside the organism.
And this is the language.
This is all we have
to work with.
So here's a simple example.
This is, how many combinations
do you have of dipeptides?
So when you start with
two amino acids.
So this is phenylalanine
and aspartic acid.
So if I told you, you have
A and B, and how many AB
mixtures can you come up with?
You'd say, well, you've
got AA, you've got BB,
and you've got AB.
You know, it's sort of
like calculus, right?
If you square A plus B,
you'd get A squared,
plus 2AB, plus B squared.
But because of chirality, AB
is distinguishable from BA.
This is cool.
This is, again, math
serving us, instead
of we serving math.
All right?
So A plus B squared
is A squared
plus 2AB plus B squared.
But no, no, not in biology.
Because AB is chiral,
and therefore
distinguishable from BA.
Now you understand chirality.
So here's--
you get four.
Because see, in this case,
phenylalanine peptide to
aspartic acid is distinguishable
from the one
on the right.
They're distinguishable.
They're different.
OK, so that let's
roll with that.
Let's say, so if I start with
two amino acids, and I want to
make dipeptides, well,
that's trivial.
That's 2 squared, is 4.
So I got four different
dipeptides, starting with two
amino acids.
Now, suppose I said, how many
different dipeptides can we
make, period?
Well, I know I've got a library
of 20 amino acids that
are found in proteins.
So that means the number of
dipeptides would be then 20
squared, which is 400.
But that's hardly
a macromolecule.
So let's get into the
macromolecule business.
So suppose I took a library of
twenty amino acids, and I
said, how many kilopeptides
could I make?
What's a kilopeptide?
A kilopeptide is something
that's got 1000
peptide bonds in it.
So that's going to be 20 to the
power of 1000, which is 10
to the power of 1300.
And this is small.
n equals 1000.
I'm not stretching the point
by pulling something
exceptional out.
A polymer, if it were polymer,
1000 units long, you'd say,
that's sort of fair to
middling length.
I'm not pulling out the longest
polymer ever known.
I didn't go to the Guinness
Book of Records for this.
This is just plain vanilla
mer length.
So look.
How much information
can be contained?
That's in a single element.
OK.
So later on we're going to
return to this, and appreciate
how we can get to such
information density.
And this I think I alluded
to on Wednesday.
These are the three-letter
initializations, and I'll post
this at the website.
So these are the airports that
correspond to the three-letter
initialization.
Then I showed you the one-letter
abbreviation for
each of the peptides.
You know, it's kind of strange,
because the amino
acids are what they are.
And most airports, they're
not like the main ones.
It's not like Boston
or New York.
It's weird places like Australia
and Texas and stuff.
You know?
So--
hey, you've got to have
a sense of humor!
Come on.
All right.
And there's glutamic acid.
There's no airport that has
GLU as its three-letter--
OK.
So here we are.
So now we want to do
is want to talk
about protein structure.
And so we're going to look at
this as material scientists.
We're not going to look at it
the way chemists, capital
C-chemists, do.
And I think by looking at it
from a structure perspective,
you get some insights
into what we can
do with these things.
So protein structure.
And I'm going to use the
terminology that the
biologists use.
So first of all, they have
something they call the
primary structure
of the protein.
And it speaks to composition,
the composition.
Well, what's the composition?
We know that every protein is
made of amino acids, and every
amino acid is virtually
identical,
except for the R group.
So when you say the composition,
you're really
saying, what is the
R sequence?
It's the amino acid sequence
down the backbone.
Because you've polymerized
this thing, or
macromolecularized it.
Amino acid sequence, which
along the backbone.
Which is really the R groups.
The sequence of R groups,
which is going to be the
sequence, OK?
All right.
So here you can see.
There's an amino
acid sequence.
Number two is the--
these are really--
you know, like the polymer
people had conformality.
You know, they had nice,
powerful words.
The first order is the primary,
and then the second
one is the secondary.
I'm trying to make fun of the
biologists, and you're sitting
there, you know, with that
same Thanksgiving
dinner table stoicism.
OK.
So what's the secondary?
The secondary structure of
proteins speaks to packing.
And what's the gambit here?
Why do they pack in
different ways?
Well, just as we saw,
you can have a long
chain, straight chain.
Sometimes things full
back on themselves.
It's still a straight chain, but
there's a curve, a bend in
it, and so on.
What proteins are going to do in
order to pack, is to try to
maximize hydrogen bonding.
And this is not even
between proteins.
This is a protein forming
on itself.
And you could argue, why do you
maximize hydrogen bonding?
Because when you make more bonds
per unit volume, you
decrease the energy
of a system.
You've been taught that
over and over again.
So these are long chain
molecules, but they still can
loop back on one another.
And if you've got a choice of
forming a dipole-dipole
interaction, a induced
dipole-induced dipole
interaction, or a hydrogen bond,
which is going to give
you the most decrease
per unit bond?
It's hydrogen.
So if you can form hydrogen
bonds, that gives you the most
impact per bond.
If you don't have hydrogen
bonding capability, then you
go for dipole-dipole.
And if you don't have
dipole-dipole, then it's just
the weak van der Waals, or
the London dispersion.
So that's why this thing goes
for hydrogen bonding.
Because it wants to.
It wants to decrease
the energy.
So I have to show you
a few cartoons here.
All right.
So here's a sketch taken from
one of the readings.
So there's alpha carbon.
This is the carboxylic
acid, right here.
And this is the peptide bond
between one carbon and a
nitrogen in an adjacent unit.
All right?
So there's the peptide bond.
The interesting thing is that
even though this is sp3
hybridized, data show that all
six atoms lie in a plane.
So what happened last
time when we came
up with this conundrum?
sp3 hybridized, but the data
showed it all lies in a plane.
That was benzene, remember?
And how do we skate with
the puck on benzene?
Resonance.
We said it resonates between two
structures, and sometimes
the nitrogen lies
in the plane.
Sometimes the alpha carbon
lies in the plane.
But thanks to resonance,
all six of these
can lie in the plane.
OK.
So now how do we get to
hydrogen bonding?
So there's the resonance.
All right.
Good.
So you see, this is free
to rotate, right?
Once we accept that these six
atoms line in a plane, and
these six atoms line in a plane,
and 109 degree angle is
fixed, but there's that degree
of rotation, which is what
gave us the original C17H36
folding back on itself, only
we're going to fold back on
ourselves in groups of six.
So we've got a deck
of cards here.
I've got six here, six
here, six here.
So what am I going to do?
I'm going to try to make this
blue plane lie relative to the
yellow plane in such a way as to
maximize hydrogen bonding.
Speaking of energy deficit,
we need battery.
All right, here we go.
So now we're going
to maximize.
Look.
You see, if I rotate this blue
plane in just the right way, I
can set up to have a hydrogen
bond form between this
hydrogen and this oxygen, and on
the orange plane, an oxygen
and a hydrogen.
So now it becomes a matter
of figuring out,
what are these angles?
You see, there's a phi
and a psi here.
What are the angles phi and
psi to give the maximum
hydrogen bonding between these
two six-packs of atoms?
And from that, you get
secondary structure.
It's all about maximizing
hydrogen bonding.
After that, if you understand
what I just
said, the rest is trivia.
So here's what happens.
Here's one structure.
And this was first discovered,
if you like, revealed, by
Linus Pauling, 1951.
Linus Pauling and Corey, 1951,
came with the realization that
if the protein spirals in a
helix, it will line up the
maximum number of
hydrogen-oxygen hydrogen
bonding opportunities, as
opposed to going straight.
So it doesn't go perfectly
straight, it coils.
And this is two different
cartoons trying to show.
So you can see peptide bonds,
and then every so often you
get a hydrogen-oxyge bond.
Because it spins around, and
the idea is, as the helix
forms, you can think of it as--
have you ever gone up a
spiral staircase?
And you think of each subsequent
turn of the spiral
as a new gallery.
And what you've got is hydrogen
bonds between the galleries.
So you're going up, and there's
a hydrogen bond here,
and you keep turning, and
there's a hydrogen bond here,
and there's a hydrogen
bond here.
That's the way to get maximum
hydrogen bonding.
There it is.
There's another example.
Maybe this is a nicer one.
And there's 3.6 residues
per turn.
That means, per turn is 3.6 R
groups, which, it's called
residues because historically,
when people did the chemical
analysis, the residue contained
the substituent.
That's how they determined
what the identity of the
protein is.
They can't just look at it.
And you can't use
spectroscopy.
Maybe now you can, but
in the old days--
I mean, these are all, look.
Low mass.
Hydrogen, oxygen, nitrogen.
They're not distinguishable.
They're all low-Z elements.
So they had to do wet chemistry,
and they would
actually peel off the
R groups, which
were called the residuals.
And so 3.6 residuals
per turn give you
this alpha helix structure.
there's a second structure
that works.
The second structure is
between two chains.
So in this case, instead of
going coiling by yourself, and
forming the galleries, what you
do is you take two chains
side by side, and you pace them
so that you get maximum
amount of hydrogen bonding.
I showed you this with nylon,
how two strands
of nylon bond together.
They can form hydrogen bonds.
Same thing here.
And now, since these are jerking
in a motion of six in
a plane, six in a plane, six
in a plane, six in a plane,
what you end up with
is this pleating.
It's hard to see here.
Maybe if your eye can follow
along the top here.
Here's sort of a cream-colored
one, orangey-cream, and it's
moving sort of southwest to
northeast. And here's one
that's sort of a grayish, and
it's moving from northwest to
southeast. And then
up, and then down.
And zig and then zag.
And this is called the
pleated sheet.
This is the beta form.
The alpha form is the helix,
and the beta form is the
pleated sheet.
Same thing up here in a
different kind of model.
Which I look at that and I go,
I don't get any information
from this thing at all.
But they put it in the books.
Who cares.
This is where you learn
something, right here.
Once you appreciate that those
six atoms have to be in a
plane, and how to maximize
hydrogen bonding.
So let's put that down.
This is all Linus Pauling.
So secondary.
So you know that six
atoms in plane,
which leads to resonance.
And now, from there, you just
needs the genius of Linus
Pauling, and then you conclude
that to maximize hydrogen
bonding, you form the alpha
helix with hydrogen bonding
between galleries.
All right?
And then the second one is the
pleated sheet, or people just
call it the sheet.
But to me, the sheet
means nothing!
It's the fact that
it's pleated.
So I'm going to ignore
what the books say.
Pleated, pleated sheet.
OK.
So this is hydrogen
bonds between
galleries of the same protein.
Whereas this is hydrogen
bonding between
macromolecules.
So if they're both pleated,
it's going to work.
Or of course, that could be
folding back on itself.
Remember how I showed you the
first day the chain, how the
chain wanted to zig-zag,
to crystallize?
Do you think protein
is liable to fold?
You've heard of protein
folding?
Why does it fold?
Because it wants to maximize
hydrogen bonding!
And when it folds, it's not
going to maximize hydrogen
bonding unless it is in
the beta pleated sheet
arrangement.
Otherwise, what's the
point of folding?
Because you can't
make the link.
Because I'm the oxygen, the
hydrogen's way over there.
If that hydrogen were
right over here, we
could form the bond.
And then the third
one is random.
So let's take a look.
I think I've got some
images here.
Oh, here's another one,
showing the-- yeah.
I'm trying to, I'm really
working hard.
Here's six, here's six,
here's six, and
there's the common carbon.
OK?
And now you can see
the hydrogen
bonds forming between.
So this could be one protein,
this could be another protein,
or this could be the same
protein that's folding back on
itself in a
pseudo-crystallization ploy.
Yeah.
All right.
So if you look in the biology
literature, you'll see
drawings like this.
You've seen these, huh?
You look at them and go, what
are they talking about?
Now you know!
This is the secondary
structure.
Let's start over here
at the amino end.
So you're moving along, and it's
just sort of random, and
now, all of a sudden, look.
Round and round and round.
What are you looking at?
For this run of length, it's
in the alpha helix form!
And then it kind of goes random
for a little bit, and
then it goes green.
And this green area
is pleated sheet.
So if the pleated sheet goes
this way, and then it goes
random, and then the pleated
sheet goes this way, what's
going to happen? there's going
to be hydrogen bonding here,
hydrogen bonding here, hydrogen
bonding here.
And you know, how is it that
this thing decides, oh,
somewhere around
here, I think.
I think I'll just go into an
alpha helix arrangement.
Why is it alpha helix here,
and not alpha helix here?
Because of the instant
choice of R groups!
The instant choice of R groups
will dictate whether it can
turn around.
Because if you've got glycene
with its dinky little hydrogen
on one side, you're compact
and you can move around.
But some of these other pendant
groups are big, and
you can't just shove them
one into the other.
They'll repel.
They won't fit.
So this dictates--
so in essence, the secondary
structure is set, the table is
set by the primary structure,
isn't it?
This is so cool.
Then there's the tertiary
structure.
Because random isn't, as they
say in California, it's not
totally random.
There's some order to it.
So let's look at the
order that comes.
See this?
Look over here.
You see up here?
This is supposed to
be random coil.
But look at it.
It's kind of dentate
there, isn't it.
See, it's sort of tooth-like.
Do you think that the artist
just did that?
Why is it like that?
Because of the molecular
forces!
So let's think on it.
Oh!
This is a little piece
from Guys and Dolls.
1951.
The same your Pauling
enunciated this.
I bet you think that when
people talk about the
chemistry between folks, that
it's a '60s phenomenon.
You know, the hippies,
drug culture.
No.
It goes way back.
Goes to the '50s.
Listen to this.
This Sky Masterson, and he's
going to tell Sarah-- she's
the one that's the,
she plays the--
what do you call it--
she works at the Salvation
Army mission.
And he's a gambler, which in
those days was really, you
know, like low-life.
And he's flirting with her,
and she, of course, has
nothing to do with him,
and eventually, they
fall in love, of course.
But anyway, so she's told him
how she's going to meet the
man of her life.
And she's very linear.
He's got all of these
characteristics, and
so on and so forth.
Real linear.
And this guy's a gambler, so
he's going to tell her how
he's going to find the
love of his life.
[BEGIN FILM PLAYBACK]
Do you want to hear how a
gambler feels about the big
heart drop?
No!
Well, I'll tell you.
Mine will come as a
surprise to me.
Mine, I leave to chance
and chemistry?
Chemistry?
Yeah, chemistry.
Suddenly I'll know when
my love comes along.
I'll know--
[END FILM PLAYBACK]
So there you have it.
From 1951.
Chemistry, again, chemistry!
Chemistry is the central thing.
OK.
Now let's go forward.
All right.
So now let's figure out why--
and now I want to answer the
question, why is this forming
a tooth-like structure?
Why?
There's a reason
for everything.
All right.
So here we are, moving along
a length of random coils.
So we're in zone three
here, random.
But it's not completely
random.
So this is the tertiary
structure, and it has to do
with interactions between
the R groups.
So let's look at number
one, zone one here.
We've got two cysteines,
and cysteine both
have sulfur in them.
It turns out that the sulfurs
can form a covalent bond here.
This is between two
R groups along a
certain length of chain.
And once that covalent bond
forms, this chain now can't
just go flopping any which
way, because it's
being held in place.
It's like you put
a prop there.
Over here, what do we
have in zone two?
We have one R group that's
got a hydroxyl.
Another one's got an oxygen.
There's a hydrogen bond forming
between side groups.
And in order to form that
hydrogen bond, can you see
that this coil is
actually bent?
You see, there's a kink here.
This coil should be
much longer, if it
were straight, distended.
But it's actually compressed
a little bit in order to
facilitate the formation
of this hydrogen bond.
Which means now, this coil
will stay in this
configuration.
And then over here,
what do we have?
Here we have a substituent group
that's net positive,
here we have a substituent group
that's net negative, and
we have an electrostatic
force.
This is coulombic.
This is plus attracts minus.
And they form.
And over here, this is
very interesting.
What do we have here?
We have a whole bunch of R
groups that are all non-polar.
And this thing's sitting
in an aqueous solution.
And what do you know about
non-polar groups in water?
They're hydrophobic!
So I've got this one
hydrophobic group
sticking out over here.
It's just going to
have to take it.
Because it's bound
to the backbone.
But I've got another
one over here, and
the backbone is flexible.
And I've got another
one over here.
Can you see that if the backbone
folds around, I can
collect all the hydrophobic
entities, and present to the
water the hydrophilic opposite
side of the backbone.
Because if the R group here is
hydrophobic, look what's on
the other side.
These guys.
So if I can take all of these
and cluster them, then I sort
of minimize the energy.
Because that there is a
repulsive energy term, right?
The water doesn't like the
non-polar R group.
So let's minimize their
contact, you know?
If you've got two siblings that
are fighting, you put
them at the other end
of the table.
You don't sit them next
to one another.
So here's what you do.
You cluster all of this
stuff, and that
causes big hairpin turn.
So this is called hydrophobic
interactions.
And that's the tertiary
structure.
So you see all of those.
That's great.
OK.
I see we're getting close
to the witching hour.
So maybe I'll teach you how to
do your laundry and send you
on your way.
So this interaction I'm just
showing you right here is the
same thing that's happening
when you do your laundry.
Now, what's a detergent?
A detergent is this long
molecule that's got-- you see
this zig-zag here?
That's the aliphatic.
That's the hydrocarbons chain.
And it is hydrophobic.
The soil on your clothing is
usually some dirt, but it's
covered by some grease
and oil.
So if you just soak it in water,
the water can't get at
the grease and oil.
So what you do, is you put these
molecules in that are
very long, and then they've got
this COO ending, right?
And now what happens?
This can form hydrogen bonds
to the water, whereas these
long hydrophobic tails can bond
to the grease and oil.
And then you put this in the
washing machine, and what's
the washing machine do?
Mechanically agitate.
So you've got these tails,
hydrophobic tails, stabbing
the grease and oil, bonded to
the water, shake the living
daylights out of this, and
release the grease and oil,
which then will release the
soil, rinse the whole thing,
and you've got clean clothing.
So it's the bonding here.
What you've got is an
amphipathic molecule with a
hydrophobic tail and a
hydrophilic head that allows
you to do your laundry.
All right.
Get out of here.
We'll see you on Wednesday.